hi I'm Erik Bosse in Terminator dark
fate has a trailer showing this sixth
Terminator film or as this movie's
producer team would happy believe the
third Terminator film yeah this story is
set after the events of t2 Judgment Day
1991 red Connie in the Terminator
history so that Terminator 3 Terminator
Salvation Terminator Genisys never
happened so remember when Sarah Connor
was some other dragons and John Connor
Christian Bale got in that fight with
the crew oh yeah me neither
king of the world James Cameron is
returning as producer to this movie as
his original Sarah Connor Linda Hamilton
with Deadpool director Tim Miller and
Mackenzie Davis from Black Mears and
Junipero and Blade Runner 2049 playing
grace a human terminator hybrid
bodyguard figure grace has come back in
time to protect Danny Ramos played by a
Natalia is who seems to be this movie's
first terminator Sarah Connor a target
on the run with some crucial role to the
wars to come by setting this story after
t2 perhaps John Connor who was played by
Edward Furlong in that 91 movie is no
longer going to be the leader of the
human resistance in the future or maybe
John died before that Skynet Judgment
Day and now there's a new target for the
time-traveling a eyes to worry about
apparently dark fate will feature
flashbacks with the likenesses of Edward
Furlong Linda Hamilton and Arnold
Schwarzenegger from tea to digitally
mapped over standards to recreate key
moments this trailer footage suggests
Terminator dark fate will be a western
roadtrip action chase story similar to
movies like Mad Max fury road or Logan
with some imagery very reminiscent of
they have awesome semi truck chase
sequence in t2 this story is set in
Mexico you can see that from highway
signs in this trailer grace at one point
appears under a bridge they can be
thinking this could be the us-mexico
border and she's nude here so this could
be her arrival scene back in time to
this point and later you can see the new
Terminator character appearing in a
detention center and what looks like
migrants and cages there's another shot
of them all riding on top a train with a
bunch of migrants so as was the case of
Logan the social issue backdrop of
immigration will be an important theme
attic influence to the story the new
upgraded c1000 of this film is played by
Gabriel Luna who has the shape-shifting
properties of Robert Patrick's t1000 he
can actually morph into two figures it
looks like perhaps the original
cybernetic skeleton and
duplicate grace is constructed
differently she has her living tissue
covering a synthetic mesh with this
yellow goo oozing out there's a close-up
of her skin showing what looks like a
tattoo with some numbers I see 30 38 58
67 this could be a serial number or
lotto numbers or her coordinates for her
destination Linda Hamilton Sarah Connor
returns for this story which yeah it's
kind of a thing these days a lot like
Jenny Lee Curtis Halloween Laurie Strode
as a former 80's final female turned
badass rocking the silver and
celebrating the end of the Second
Amendment sure it's a Hollywood trend
but I'm kind of digging it so Sarah
Connor is still her t2 warrior self
sunglasses heavy artillery she takes out
both be primary terminator it is
duplicate self remember mt2 she kept a
cache a filled with this kind of
artillery in this general region perhaps
at the end of t2 Sarah and John followed
through on Sarah's plans to flee to
Mexico and continued to prepare for the
coming war arnold schwarzenegger is also
returning which you know isn't saying
much because this guy comes back for all
the Terminator movies even the ones
we're supposed to forget here he's
playing an aging Terminator with his
living tissue over cybernetic skeleton
aging like normal flesh does he's a t800
model 101 recruited by Sarah to help
protect Danny now it doesn't totally
make sense because remember that t800
from t2 was melted in an industrial
furnace maybe another t800 was sent back
I'm sure it all makes sense the other
Terminator movies are really great about
explaining how it all worked there is
some great action teased throughout this
trailer mid-air cargo plane collision
where the team 1000 served jumps from
one plane to the other and then this
parachuting Humby with grease hanging
from the platform but really what I
liked the most was the music choice
this is a cover of hunter originally
recorded by Bjork in 1997 the lyrics are
all about hunting never stopping a
relentless chase and Bjork's music video
for this song is awesome
Bjork transforms into a techno polar
bear to convey the music's fusion of
organic and technological sounds to
becomes the ferocious bear hunter of the
lyrics similarly these terminators
transform with a fusion of organic
tissue and technological material into
ferocious relentless hunters comment
down below with your thoughts on this
trailer in this new Terminator film
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at EA
bossom subscribe to new rock stars for
deep dives and breakdowns into
everything that you love thanks for
watching and oh hey Christian Bale what
do you think of what we do here at new
rock stars shake man your amateur
[Music]